Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute Papers
with Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
Now that facial recognition is becoming more
and more of a hot topic, let's talk a bit
about 3D face reconstruction!
This is a problem where we have a 2D input
photograph, or a video of a person, and the
goal is to create a piece of 3D geometry from
it.
To accomplish this, previous works often required
a combination of proper alignment of the face,
multiple photographs and dense correspondences,
which is a fancy name for additional data
that identifies the same regions across these
photographs.
But this new formulation is the holy grail
of all possible versions of this problem,
because it requires nothing else but one 2D
photograph.
The weapon of choice for this work was a Convolutional
Neural Network, and the dataset the algorithm
was trained on couldn't be simpler: it was
given a large database of 2D input image and
3D output geometry pairs.
This means that the neural network can look
at a lot of these pairs and learn how these
input photographs are mapped to 3D geometry.
And as you can see, the results are absolutely
insane, especially given the fact that it
works for arbitrary face positions and many
different expressions, and even with occlusions.
However, this is not your classical Convolutional
Neural Network, because as we mentioned, the
input is 2D and the output is 3D.
So the question immediately arises: what kind
of data structure should be used for the output?
The authors went for a 3D voxel array, which
is essentially a cube in which we build up
the face from small, identical Lego pieces.
This representation is similar to the terrain
in the game Minecraft, only the resolution
of these blocks is finer.
The process of guessing how these voxel arrays
should look based the input photograph is
referred to in the research community as volumetric
regression.
This is what this work is about.
And now comes the best part!
An online demo is also available where we
can either try some prepared images, or, we
can also upload our own.
So while I run my own experiments, don't leave
me out of the good stuff and make sure you
post your results in the comments section!
The source code is also available for you
fellow tinkerers out there.
The limitations of this technique includes
the inability of detecting expressions that
are very far away from the ones seen in the
training set, and as you can see in the videos,
temporal coherence could also use some help.
This means that if we have video input, the
reconstruction has some tiny differences in
each frame.
Maybe a Recurrent Neural Network, like some
variant of Long Short Term Memory could address
this in the near future.
However, those are trickier and more resource-intensive
to train properly.
Very excited to see how these solutions evolve,
and of course, Two Minute Papers is going
to be here for you to talk about some amazing
upcoming works.
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!